[Music]
well I got this um like this whole kit
here and a gift like goodie bag thing at
an event that I went to a couple years
ago
so we're gonna just cross our fingers
and hope that the ingredients are still
good so it comes with sprinkles it came
with these like hats iron.most we just
season those two yeah it was fun oil and
then came with this really beautiful
whisk and it came with with these so
it's gingerbread cookie mix sugar cookie
mix and frosting mix you will need 1 and
1/2 teaspoons of softened butter
teaspoon baby I mean tables free often
do better I don't remember any of my
baking skills that I had when I was 9
years old
the most recent baking experience I've
had was to make those oatmeal cookies
you know how long ago that was a year
ago and I said I'm gonna make more
babies listen guys you don't know this
behind the things it's been a tough year
man I know how disappointing
I apologize so we're gonna open this up
I think that's this how you do it right
like it doesn't say melted butter though
softened yeah I would do like five
seconds seconds nothing the next thing
is free I mean combined cookie mix
butter and egg in a small bowl mix what
you're right it melted 15 seconds is too
long oh well that's okay I put 15
seconds 2020 told ya Mike does combine
cooking mix butter and egg so you could
throw the butter in here so it didn't
say to crack the egg so you're right oh
yeah leave the shows on we want crunchy
cookies you want to do this yes you got
butter on your hands
[Music]
sorry I have spoken like a true YouTube
child don't make that sound
do you remember Isaac when we made a
gingerbread a gingerbread man that was -
yes whoa careful and then when we made
the rice krispies treats and Alice yeah
I remember those yeah so we woke up a
couple see yeah you want to be careful
with the flour coming out so chocolate
I'm coming for Christmas ooh my brother
hit me up asking me for our address and
he wants to send us an oyster shucker
and a box of oysters Christmas taste it
I taste like the small little cookie
dough I mean
flower doesn't flower it does it's one
of those you gotta cook it first
you look flower do you think you're good
let me be funny we just gotta cook it
okay if I get sick did I have your
permission medical school but I'm like
well you don't want to get sick when
you're on a vacation already okay that's
true I suggest you bring this over and
then you spoon it in you singing the
nfl's so it's a bake for 10 to 12
minutes or until done remove skillet
from the oven using and oven mitts be
careful the handle will be very hot
decorate with sprinkles and frosting and
served repeat with remaining dough
do you still believe in Santa Claus
what since what forever since forever
so who's been getting you all those
presents all these years you mom care
you mama ye yes you in mountain really
yeah I ask them like how close were
there years that you believe like the
word there it was there a time that you
did believe in Santa Claus do you
remember those times not really to be
honest I forgot him yeah you were too
young and then already you're already
losing your memories your childhood
memories or your infant merit memories
yeah crazy do you remember your infinite
memories nope I think my earliest
memories are around six everything
before that is really really foggy they
having fun in the races know what I
remember so hard this was good I know
this is the frosting mix put the list
this is beautiful that's beautiful like
my childhood memories frosting is the
smell of your childhood what can I show
this you have no no no this is what I'm
really gonna just wing it
[Music]
okay you know would be a really cool
cooking show the fresh-grated chef
Gordon Ramsay's competence I should use
this bowl for this and this bowl for
this yeah see that's the fresh fish
[Music]
[Music]
today work though we've left her out
she's on the time crunch the like the
cooking shows everything's burning
there's nothing even the milk is biting
for no reason even the Commons building
[Music]
[Music]
getting fat and clumping you know maybe
it's for a minute
mornin browner
ain't golden-brown let me use a
toothpick toothpick test oh yeah you're
done
[Music]
why does this one look like Patrick and
SpongeBob mixed together there good
answer would you like to do ballroom
dancing salsa dancing this is a sugar
cookie yeah this looks like bread I put
some little milk
it does look like bread oh it's like
sweet bread like a good kind of bread
[Music]
because you know I never really read the
instructions either cuz it says if it's
too thick stirring more milk a few drops
at a time I should have known something
was something was off when it asks for a
half of teaspoon of milk
[Music]
you know what you could do instead
there's just use of frosting as a
dipping sauce and just dip the cookie as
needed you like that idea and then to go
back
Oh what happened pretty oh so pretty I
feel pretty and witty and those who
think something that impressed
oh do the sprinkle bay sprinkle bay the
thirties calm sabe oh these are
sprinkles I know I know but I was just
saying you're such a dad you're making a
Mexican flag gingerbread estée noise
[Music]
how'd you know I like the tree you're a
nature guy yay and I make starry girl
but you're a spongebob remember you're a
star you're patrick star and he's like
you're spongebob you at the trophy
episode I was like what has been your
most favorite Christmas that you've
spent that you have in recent memories
because we've had many Christmases last
year we spent Christmas in Hong Kong
that was cool I like that we've been to
to New Orleans on Christmas Day or
Houston I remember even when you were
really really little when we used to
have this did he pass spent we spent
Christmas at Disney
I think that this new one might be a
mite might have been my favorite you
don't even remember it you were like two
years old I remember whenever you make
those tuna cakes isn't anything like
this the tuna capes ya know cuz that's
like cooking it's not baking Jeremy yeah
I remember amazed Christmas cookies oh
yeah you know I actually want to make
them on this for Christmas because I
noticed that I didn't it never really
instilled any Mexican traditions in you
like you don't know
very little about your culture mm-hmm
and so for me when I was a kid every
Christmas I used to help my grandma make
the - wasn't it a stage to me no it's
just tedious but it doesn't take a whole
day because also when we make them
unless like growing up it was because we
wanted to eat them for like the whole
month of December so it would make the
time I've been craving you to like
desperately can you say tamales with the
with the proper accent - yeah
[Music]
well this I'm not a big sugar fan one
thing you have to know about me if I put
too much sugar on and I'm gonna be like
it's like a one bite thing that huh well
it's very sweet I think I'm good bye
so you guys are created then if you
don't like sweetness like this like that
what did anything stick yeah a little
more having that
oh yeah sure just Brett the oh oh the
green is wiping off but I can stain it
now to eyeball it's a ninja turtle bread
these are totally different
sugar cookies than what you speed stores
that's true
I like mommy's cookie the best it's the
most like edible looking one mine just
looks like I gave up on decoration or
stuffing all this stuff to it and then
Isaac's
you're the over ear cookie decorator and
definitely guys I do not recommend vegan
butter true it would smell a lot better
in here was regular butter and probably
tastes better too
and I also don't recommend you use a
three-year-old ingredients but we tasted
it yeah I kind of don't even wanna try
this there you go folks that's the
cooking video here at the Chan plan
house cookie making video yeah where you
just don't overdo it
I'll go down to the bottom of them I'm a
team player my cookie vegan butter
three-year-old see how they're gonna go
two-year-old two-year-old uh ingredient
you got bad definitely not have to do
you tell you that good it's like a
biscuit
not a fan we forgot the butter
I just thought vegan butter would be
alright so you knew we had vegan butter
it tastes pink you cringy boy everybody
I'm cream G cream G Isaac this is not a
cookie it's bread
this is nuts my cookie it's not the
cookies bread it was a fun activity yay
great results maybe we can add some oh
good god yeah I mean we can just remove
the cookie all together in Justin
[Music]
[Music]